no habían pasado 24 horas desde la caída
masiva de facebook y otras redes
sociales cuando joven denuncia que a los
responsables de la plataforma les
interesan más las ganancias que el
bienestar de los jóvenes de que formas
puntuales las redes sociales afectan a
los adolescentes
bueno de muchas el mundo y la realidad
afecta a los adolescentes y cualquier
escenario que está entre la familia y el
mundo es un escenario de tránsito para
los adolescentes y es un escenario en el
cual hay que cuidarlo justo había una
noticia recién que daban ustedes
sobre el tema de los abusos es decir son
distintos los escenarios siempre en el
escenario social es un escenario donde
puede haber cuidado o agua pueden haber
descuidos las redes sociales es un lugar
que tenemos que estar atentos por
supuesto en este tipo de compañías no
tienen unos departamentos de ética unos
lineamientos que sean controlados por
alguien externos es momento de
considerar la autorregulación
empresarial
valentina yo no sé si
obviamente que sí habrá habrá que pensar
regulaciones con respecto a las empresas
a mí igual creo que que los ciudadanos
del futuro van a ser ciudadanos que van
a tener que administrar aprender a
administrar o tener una política de
administración de todo lo que se nos
ofrece porque se nos ofrece mucho se nos
ofrece en abundancia para que consumamos
y vamos a tener que aprender a
administrar ese tipo de estímulos por
supuesto que las regulaciones y lo que
se puede hacer con las empresas ayudará
por
qué pueden hacer los padres porque
justamente la adolescencia suele ser una
época en la que los jóvenes se alejan
buscando independencia entonces es una
oposición de los padres puede tener un
efecto contraproducente
siempre es una difícil pregunta la de
los padres porque siempre hay un de más
o un de menos en la acción de los padres
y limitar sino limitarse y permitir sino
permitir yo creo que en ese sentido se
pueden usar los mismos recursos que se
usan con cualquier adolescente en
cualquier otro escenario que es fomentar
la responsabilidad la confianza no justo
el testimonio de esta mujer de francia
ella le había podido contar a su madre
solo que sobre lo que le había pasado
pero no me parece que ese es un dato
importante de que los nuestros hijos
tengan la confianza o el canal de
comunicación abierto para decirnos algo
de lo que se les está ocurriendo por
supuesto hay que estar cerca y hay que
aprender hay que enseñarles a
administrar
y de qué manera circular por esos
ámbitos todos no porque también la calle
las instituciones como las redes
sociales son ámbitos en donde pueden
pasar muchas cosas si un niño está
perdido